today I'll stick to football there's a
game on tonight I have heard Monday
night national championship game Clemson
Tigers LSU Tigers Death Valley verse
death valley myself Matt Miller Connor
Rodgers we were gonna break this game
down player by player buddy and then in
the show with a lot of draft on draft
fun yeah this is the draft preview of
the national championship and it's one
you're gonna want to listen to because
looking at this rundown you can go
through nearly every starter on the
field that's draft eligible and their
name matters in this class it's really
something and I'm curious to see you
know if if the Senior Bowl is waiting on
a couple announcements from these guys
after the game obviously we're excited
to see some of these guys especially the
Clemson players who have had some big
games this year but we want to see more
from them under the spotlight and like
matt said we're gonna get through your
draft on draft questions but we have to
start with around the league there are
some things going on the Browns finally
make a hire as we're recording this show
they're setting up or finishing up
interviews with GM's and really really
exciting two weeks of NFL playoffs so
far but one more reminder before we get
into the show
if you're going to the Senior Bowl we
are doing not one but two live shows
that is January 20th January 22nd those
are the Monday and Wednesday nights both
at 7:30 p.m. same time same place draft
picks in Mobile Alabama that is draft
picks taproom we always have a good time
and if you're gonna be down in Miami for
the Super Bowl or you're looking for an
excuse to go on February 1st that is the
Saturday before the game we will be
having an event a Super Bowl event will
get you exact location details but it
will be at 1 p.m. in Miami Florida in
the Super Bowl media area it's gonna be
a great time I'm looking forward to
mobile we'll be there in one week you're
listening this Monday maybe Tuesday
morning we will be boots on the ground
in Mobile it's gonna be a great time
like Connor said 7:30 draft picks tap
room for the live podcast we're gonna
have things to give away we're gonna do
the show for you we'll take your
questions to be a good time let's jump
into the news though you touched on it
they're counter to the Browns they've
completed the hiring cycle every team
now has a head coach the Browns hire
Kevin Stefanski offensive coordinator
for the Minnesota Vikings and
you know we're all true detective fans
here at stick to football and time is a
flat circle buddy because this is a guy
that the Browns tried to or we're
interested in hiring one year ago
instead they went with Freddie kitchens
Baker Mayfield said hey I want Freddie
they got Freddie and a lot of folks in
that front office and in that ownership
group one in Kevin Stefanski notably
Paul D Podesta who has a lot of power
with that team now Stefanski comes in
maybe not off the best performance he's
put together as an offensive coordinator
the Vikings could not do anything
against that San Francisco 49ers pass
rush that was just all over Kirk Cousins
and I think this isn't interesting hire
let's talk about Stefanski and then
we'll get into some of the other front
office type things happening here I look
at the talent the Cleveland has on
offense and this is a dangerous game to
play because I think we did this last
year but you have Baker Mayfield you
have Nick Chubb you have Odell Beckham
jr. Jarvis Landry I would probably try
to patch things up with David and Joe ku
now that everyone else is gone they have
some talent and when I look at what
Kevin was able to do in Minnesota with
less talent then the Browns have you
gotta feel pretty good about that I
think step one is obvious for this
obvious for this team you have to build
the offensive line now Stefanski was
able to have a not great offensive line
in Minnesota instead of a productive
offense so I don't think his offense is
necessarily predicated on having to have
the Dallas Cowboys offensive line or the
Oakland Raiders offensive line but they
do need to improve their especially at
left tackle but if you are focused on
okay we have to make a hire that's gonna
help Baker Mayfield it probably came
down to Stefanski and Josh McDaniels
because of that and I am excited to see
Baker in this offense where I think
they'll utilize a lot of rollouts try to
and also number one job for him as a
coach Baker has to learn to step up in
the pocket because and just as I was
saying Oh Lou utilize rollouts Baker was
prematurely rolling out so many times
last year and I said this about mahomes
last year so this isn't me just taking
shots to Baker he's got to learn to step
up in the pocket to make place this was
a really really interesting coaching
cycle of interviews for the Browns
because it obviously lingered longer
than any other job that was open they
took their time they didn't rush it
really seems like or I could tell you it
came down to josh mcdaniels kevin
Stefanski and robert sala and ultimately
it really came down to kevin Stefanski
and robert solow because josh mcdaniels
comes in and he asks for a lot and I
think if Josh McDaniels came in he would
have had to fully have the owner's
blessing to do things his exact way and
I think that would have pushed Paul
DePodesta out honestly so you have Paul
dude Podesta who's running a lot of
things there he wanted Kevin Stefanski
year ago he lost that battle against
John Dorsey when they went with Freddie
kitchens instead he wins this time so
McDaniels wasn't going to get all the
things he wanted there and that pushed
him out right away
now what I can tell you is Robert Sela
had a great great interview a great plan
and it leads to the next thing here this
was a team that requested to interview
Edie Dodds as the GM and if you noticed
it lingered for a while if that would
actually happen that's because he was
only coming if Robert salad got the job
Stefanski gets the job
Dodd's declines the interview and says
no thanks we have unfinished business
and Indy that wouldn't have been the
case if Robert Solow went there so no
matter what you think is Stefanski and
I'm very you know in the middle on this
hire because Gary Kubiak has helped a
lot in Minnesota this year Mike Zimmer
is the first guy in every press
conference to say that so I don't think
this is a great hire I don't think this
is a disaster hire it's just somewhere
in the middle I think the bigger problem
I have with it Matt is that the best GM
candidate for the Browns was Edie dots
and I think Robert Solow was a good head
coaching candidate yeah so if you got
Sala then Dodds and assuming you were
probably going to get one of the guys
from San Francisco which is Mike
McDaniel or Mike Lafleur as your
offensive coordinator with Saleh I liked
that package as a whole much better for
Cleveland yeah and I'll tell you the
Niners would they would block Mike
McDaniel the only way he's leaving there
Joey's head coach and Michael a floor
would be I think a little bit of a
different story but Kyle Shanahan is a
master at his guys not getting loose and
Robert Sol is gonna be a head coach next
year I'm willing to guarantee that you
can act cold takes it's gonna happen one
thing that I have heard though Connor is
that with the with Ed Dodds declining
I kind of got the feeling that he might
have done that even if Sally got the job
just because of where things were at and
one thing that can't be underrated in
this whole thing
John Dorsey being fired by the Browns
and they're gonna say oh we mutually
parted ways John Dorsey being fired is
affecting the Browns ability to hire a
GM which is why it's probably gonna be
Andrew berry whatever the title is but
John Dorsey whatever y'all think him is
so highly respected around the NFL and
his his tree his outreach is enormous I
mean guys like ed Dodds are connected to
John Dorsey and so I think with that you
know if you want to talk to like the
guys in Seattle with a fitter or
incursion er John Dorsey they're
probably gonna call John be like hey
should we should we even talk to the
Browns and guess what he's gonna say
absolutely not or if you were Mike Berg
on Z in Kansas City John Dorsey is a
mentor of yours are you gonna take that
Browns job no you're not and so with
Dorsey who's a stand-up dude I don't
think he would be you know behind closed
doors calling people saying don't take
the Browns job they screwed me over but
you're gonna you're gonna call a guy
who's been there and asked what that
situation is like so I do think the
Browns it's not a good look when you're
the last team to hire a coach even if
you could say you were waiting for Kevin
Stefanski but unless he's bringing Gary
Kubiak I'm a little skeptical that hire
but now you don't have a GM and the
senior Bowls in one week and I don't
know if people understand how important
that is that you need a structure in
place because you want to be able to go
down there knowing what you're looking
for what type of wide receivers does my
coach one what type of player does our
GM want to draft and we're gonna hear a
lot about analytics coming out of
Cleveland again it seems like they're
recycling that a little bit to where
this will be you know with John Dorsey
it was all football guy I think now
they're gonna skew back a little heavier
toward the analytics of things we'll see
what happens but it is it is very
interesting there's always drama in
Cleveland that is one thing that you can
bet on every year now the Division one
divisional round excuse me was for the
best football games that I can remember
watching in a long long time three of
them especially being very very close
games you know the Niners a Vikings game
was not but the Chiefs Texans game is
the big
like rollercoaster of emotion that I can
remember all my friends are Chiefs fans
my six-year-olds a Chiefs fan living in
Missouri your whole life like almost
everyone's the Chiefs in and when they
went down 24 nothing my son is just
despondent you know he's like what is
going on why are we losing the Texans
are gonna win and you know my friends
Melos texted me like what what the hell
is going on and then that was the flu
kiyose 24 nothing I've ever seen in my
life by the way
but then for Kansas City to turn around
I score 51 points in the final three
quarters I don't want to sit here and be
a prisoner of the moment or be a homer
because Derek Henry is really really
hard to tackle I don't know how you
couldn't watch Kansas City play on
Sunday and think yeah we could beat that
team because they erased a 24 nothing
lead in like three minutes I don't know
I don't think I've ever seen anything
like that even the Patriots twenty-eight
three come back and the playoffs was
like methodical you're they chipped away
at it the Chiefs you like went to the
bathroom and came back and they were
tired I mean let's me real I've never
felt at 24/7 that a game was over for
the team with 24 points it was right how
easily that first touchdown came and the
stadium got loud and mahomes gets
excited and the team starts following
that energy you're like oh [ __ ] if they
get one stop here like the Texans needed
to put the foot on the gas right there
you can't consumes the Chiefs got that
stop which he knew they were getting the
game was over he was over it was and
like you said Matt it was like they
spotted the Texans 24 points it didn't
feel like this authentic like wow this
is an ass-kicking right now don't get me
wrong the Texans did some good things
there but there was definitely some
fluky plays where you're sitting there
in the gun once the Chiefs offense gets
going once they get that foot on the gas
pedal and once they get a little bit of
momentum this crowd this franchise
quarterback and especially that coaching
staff is gonna carry them through and
they did Frank Clark had a great game
especially the great second half he's
really turned it on now that he's
healthy you know he was battling a lot
of things this season and and that looks
like a great move
I'm with you right now it would be and I
know Tennessee's been great to watch
they force you to play their style
football which is ugly and it punches
you in the face and I do think it will
at least be a game but to not picture
the Kansas City Chiefs in the Super Bowl
right now would just be insane it is man
it is you know the drop passes early and
then the block punt the muffs of the
muffed punt by Tyree keel it really just
felt like nothing was going to Chiefs
way I want to credit Andy Reid because
in the years past we've talked about
Andy being too conservative with the
lead I thought they did a great job son
Dave like you said foot on the gas never
letting up now the rest of these games I
look at Tennessee and I actually we do
radio here locally I picked Tennessee to
beat Baltimore and everyone crushed me
as they probably should have because it
was not a trendy pick but I just I
really believed that Mike Vrabel had a
plan and that he had enough talent on
defense to match up with what the Ravens
were gonna do now I could not have
predicted that Lamar Jackson was gonna
struggle the way he did or that the
Titans were gonna win by throwing the
ball 15 times in a game then they win by
16 points but I think when you have
Derrick Henry and you have Rashad Evans
Kenny Vaccaro Kevin Byard this is a
really really good Titans team and I
think it's time that we stop overlooking
them now that they're in AFC
championship game because they've had
some big wins this year and they are
proving that they can play with anyone
they beat Kansas City earlier this year
now there were a blocked field goal in a
missed field goal by Kansas City it was
my homes first game back from the knee
injury but my early look at this game is
I would as if like Melo were sitting
here he would tell you this as a Chiefs
fan he's terrified of the Titans and has
been since Shea got in the playoffs that
was something we talked about before the
playoff started was the Chiefs could
probably hold their own against anyone
in this division except for the Titans
and when I look at them and I don't know
how you stopped Derrick Henry I don't
know how you get past that defense
there's gonna be a fantastic game at
Arrowhead well number one the nine and a
half point line on that game was the
most disrespectful thing I've ever sat
Tennessee and I love Baltimore they had
a bad game in a lot of places that
Warren just Lamar Jackson that's what's
crazy it's like
everything came crashing down at once
for this football team and you see how
good of a coach how underrated of a
coach Mike Vrabel is but not and a half
points it was just absolutely insane and
it was so insane that it almost psyched
me out I was betting on this game
because living in New Jersey get the
luxury of Glee and I bought a point and
made it ten and a half I was like
touchdown the field goal they'll be fine
they won by a lot so I think everything
was fine and like I said do I believe
the Chiefs will be in the Superbowl yes
but do I think it'll be an easy path
against Tennessee no because of the way
they make you play is so different than
a lot of teams it really is old school
football and I think as a Titans fan
it's very exciting and I'll say this
Derek Henry has made himself a lot of
money this postseason
where he's gonna be the next great
interesting running back negotiation in
football and it's gonna be very soon
yeah he and Melvin Gordon hit the market
this year I think he'll make more than
Melvin Gordon kid it's finding the right
market for him finding the right fit
where a team wants to run the ball like
that I wouldn't be shocked if Tennessee
is able to keep Ryan Tannehill if they
use the franchise tag on Derek Henry now
in the NFC the Niners just absolutely
destroyed the Vikings 27 10 and it
didn't feel that close as the rezident
Niners fan here I'll tell you the one
thing I'm worried about is did not look
good throwing the ball and this is not a
great secondary just the fact I mean
gruffalo was 11 and 1931 yards one
touchdown one interception
Sanchez asked right and George killed
did nothing in this game now credit to
Vikings Erik Kendrick is a great
linebacker anthe bars great linebacker
they have two very good safeties
Harrison Smith Harris and Smith not
Harrison Smith and they shut this off
fence down now the Niners didn't have to
be great on office because of what they
did on defense Nick Bosa continues to
just dominate he had two sacks two
tackles for loss if you were a first
round pick by the Niners you had a sack
in this game basically but looking ahead
to Green Bay and I know the Niners
destroyed them last time they played
back in November Green Bay's offense is
getting right at the right time and so
I'm not here to like market the NFL make
these games seem more exciting than they
are as a Niners fan I am worried about
Green Bay because they can run the ball
they can throw the ball and they have
pass rushers much like the Niners do and
Preston
Smith they got a very very good corner
in sire Jared Alexander I'm worried
about the Packers this game being in San
Francisco that's not much of a
home-field advantage
the Packers man I mean Rodgers it's just
that throw that he had late in the game
where he just drops it in the bucket
only like two people in the NFL could
probably make that throw maybe three
I'll throw Drew Brees in there still
and it's just like Rodgers when the
playoffs come around we've seen some
years where it's like oh he's falling
apart this year it was like all
regular-season I was like man is he
taking a step back and the playoffs come
and it's like nope he's still really
really good this team went 13 and 3 for
a reason so we get the 1 seed versus the
2 seed and then we get the 2 seed versus
the 6 seed in the AFC but I'm worried
about the Packers I'll tell you that I
mean this is a Clash of the Titans
matchup just because you look at what
San Francisco wants to do they want to
run the football
they have multiple running backs that
can get you to that 100 yard mark this
weekend is obviously Tevin Coleman but
they have a lot of guys in that
backfield that can get them combined so
almost the 200-yard mark then you look
at the Green Bay defense the leading
rusher out of the running backs for
Seattle was Marshawn Lynch with 26 yards
2.2 yards of carry so Russell Wilson had
64 but it's on scrambles and I don't
think Jimmy's gonna be doing a lot of
that so would I always bet on Kyle
Shanahan yes but I do love the
experience of Aaron Rodgers how talented
this defense is the Darius Smith is the
most underrated defensive player in all
of NFL Aaron Jones has been phenomenal
Davante Adams is the best route runner
in football Green Bay is a lot of fun
they've been there before and Kyle
Shanahan's been this far in the
postseason before as well so I think
this is gonna be awesome I think this is
a really hard game to predict and it's
you know like I said you know the Niners
having the pass rushers to get after
Rodgers is what's gonna be the
difference in this one if they win or
not because you know Green Bay's defense
is gonna bring it but Shanahan will get
them enough I think on the offensive
side of the ball so we're set for a
really fun championship weekend I mean I
think you look at these teams and they
can all play defense now now the cheese
ironically might be the team where it's
sometimes they just don't play defense
but they're also the team that could
score
sixty points in a flash so doesn't
matter and that's why I think we're
really due for such an exciting to
really close games staring the
championship weekend since you don't
have a dog in the fight here are you are
you rooting for a cheap Schneider
Superbowl sub mellow and I just tear
each other apart for two weeks without
doubt and I also really really like Kyle
Shanahan and Pat mahomes yeah so
watching those two guys alone in the
Superbowl is a big reason now I also
really like Mike Vrabel so the Titans
don't really like their NFL I don't
think is hoping for Tennessee Ryan
Tannehill in the Superbowl but if they
get there like Mike Vrabel is awesome
they're an awesome team I think we
haven't talked about enough since they
Jeffrey Simmons has been back they've
lost like two games he's so good yeah
he's we all knew that was gonna happen
but the facts of how quickly he came
back I mean there's a lot of good that
can happen in this Super Bowl whether
it's Aaron Rodgers in it whether it's
Shanahan's Redemption story or honestly
the most important one to me though is
seeing Pat mahomes in the Super Bowl
because he's the most exciting player in
the NFL absolutely yes before we take a
break I do want to throw this nugget in
we're waiting for player declarations
they have a couple days to declare and
then a week January 20th is the deadline
to withdrawal so the 17th deadline did
to enter 20th deadline to withdrawal
we're waiting for LSU and Clemson
obviously we're waiting for some Iowa
guys but Connor one thing I heard Monday
morning when making calls getting
updates is that USC might get Austin
Jackson back which is gonna be huge if
they get offensive tackle who I think
has a chance to be a top 50 pick but USC
has a chance to get Austin Jackson back
thus I have a very good chance to get
Tyler Vaughn's back a redshirt junior
receiver so we've talked a lot about USC
being able to recruit be able to keep
their own guys getting those two players
back on offense to be pretty huge for
what they've got coming back next year
yeah that would be gigantic and I think
when you look at Jackson you know we've
now seen a couple good offensive line
prospects go back to school you know you
look at Trey Smith going back to school
yeah and then Creed Humphrey going back
to school so those are two really big
names and I think Jackson is another day
two offensive tackle that you know he's
almost penciled in as a day two
offensive tackle that takes three guys
off the board and in
a line class that's a big hit yeah and
we're still waiting for naxi Harris's
well I'm told that decision is coming I
don't think he's gonna come out you know
I was talking to I got asked to consult
on this when I was talking to some
people Friday and said you know next
year's running back class doesn't have a
dude in it but your running back how
many more hits do you want to take
before you get to the NFL so I I do you
know you see both sides of this but it's
starting to sound like nas you might
might go back I mean if you're on the
fence this late in the game I think Nick
Saban will probably get his talons India
and pull you back to Tuscaloosa but
definitely something to watch as we look
to the big names right let's take a
break we come back speaking of big names
a lot of them will be on the field
tonight in the college one national
championship game we're gonna give you
player by player with some scouting
Nuggets on each guy one team was
expected to be here when the season
began the Clemson Tigers they continue
another undefeated season ripping
through the ACC ripping through Ohio
State quarterback Trevor Lawrence has
never lost a game of college football on
the other side a bit of an underdog when
the season started one of us idiots
picked LSU to lose to Texas they didn't
lose the game all year recorded by Joe
burrow breaking records throwing 455
touchdowns completing 77 percent of his
passes while LSU went undefeated through
a tough SEC schedule Connor
we look at these two teams man and with
Clemson the one thing that stands out to
me and we're gonna go player by player
but I want to start here Trevor Lawrence
is not draft eligible so we aren't even
talking about arguably the best prospect
in this game is a guy we can't talk
about yet because he's a true sophomore
Trevor Lawrence go ahead and put him in
QB one for me
2021 barring injury or him holding up ur
liquor a liquor store he's gonna be the
guy next year
Trevor special we've seen it now for two
seasons so I don't want people to think
we're forgetting about the guy he's just
not draft eligible no and the same could
be said for Justin Ross who could be the
top wide receiver next year or one of
the top wide receivers next year so two
of the front line players the superstars
in this game are not draft eligible and
god they're just amazing I mean you go
back to what they did in the nati last
year it's gonna be fun to watch
obviously to see what Trevor can do on
another big moment this year and I think
when you talk about this LSU team I mean
they proven me wrong every step of the
way
I thought their ranking I was surprised
at their preseason ranking and they've
gotten everything and more and that
starts with Joe burrow but we are gonna
start with this Clemson team mat player
by player and I think the first one we
have to start with is the guy that shows
up in the top 10 most of the time top 15
in all of our mock traps this year and
that's I guess we'll say linebacker but
really do it all man
Isiah Simmons yeah and people ask me for
player comps on him all the time we've
talked about it a lot on the show I
don't have one and I probably won't have
one it'll probably be blank or some type
of hybrid player one nugget I've heard
and when you're watching the game
tonight Isiah Simmons it's gonna be very
easy to focus on for this Clemson
defense because he's all over the field
it will actually be a fun game for you
guys at home just track where he lines
up middle linebacker slot coroner safety
edge rusher but one thing I have heard
is that we in the media are higher on
him then a lot of teams are right now
he's my number 5 overall player think
he's he's a mellows top 5 Connor he's in
your top 10 I believe or I know he's in
your top 10 but with Isiah Simmons I
think there's a knock right now for
metafile teams that they don't know what
he is either and they're looking at that
as a negative instead of the positive
that we are so with with Simmons tonight
he's got a big job whether it's
shadowing you know Clyde Edwards a layer
whether it's getting after Joe burrow
whatever the task is for him covering
Thad Moss it tied in we're gonna see
Isiah Simmons be put in a lot of
different situations I'm a huge fan and
I think you can make the easy argument
that outside of Trevor Lawrence he's the
best player for Clemson this year yeah
he's incredible he really is the amount
of different things he could do for your
defense and I have him at 10th overall
I'm kind of in the same boat where I'm
like where is he gonna play full time
and then I kind of sit there and go
we'll just play him obviously it's you
always say on the field and move them
all over you like yeah I mean he could
play single high he could play outside
linebacker you can play inside
linebacker you could rush the passer he
does so many things really really well I
think more of me having him at 10 is
that we see players like this Matt that
are our chess piece kind of players they
fall all the time they're more talented
he's a top 10 player you could see him
going more in the top 15 which might be
great news for a team like the Las Vegas
Raiders that can use a guy like Simmons
but I think he's gonna test very well
and once again if you watch him tonight
in the national championship
see the versatility on display every
single game it absolutely yes let's move
on the best player offensively wide
receiver T Higgins I like T a lot six
foot four 215 pounds he could stretch
the field vertically he could be
physical catch point I think he's good
in the red zone but there are speed
questions and I think with T tonight
we're gonna see him against the
secondary that has Christian Fulton
derrick Stingley junior grant Delpit
quick carry vintage in yer there's a lot
of good defenders in that LSU secondary
can he separate and especially when he's
matched up with Stingley who has size
and speed that's the key for me that's
what I want to watch tonight can he get
open can to get loose because no
disrespect to the ACC not a lot of great
corners and I think against Ohio State
we saw Higgins get slowed down a little
bit yes there was the injury but he got
slowed down a little bit by Jeff Okuda
in those corners so for me with t
Higgins round one grade top 32 player I
have him right now I had 13 overall but
I do think there are some questions
about his ability to separate that I'm
gonna watch tonight I will say one thing
because I just pulled up my notes
he's gaming is Virginia this year might
be the best game any prospect had though
he's had some big stretches I mean I
think there was a three to four week
span where he had seven touchdowns so he
takes over at times I have him 21st on
my board right now and he's a great
above the rim kind of player now you
make a great point about the speed
issues Matt because you know out of high
school he was time to the 475 and I'm
not saying T Higgins is running a four
seven at the NFL Combine I think he's
gonna do much better than that but when
you're talking about is he gonna be in
this class that forget rugs forget Judy
you know the real thing is is t gonna be
a four or five guy cuz that's what you
want him to be as a six foot four player
that plays above the rim can work the
middle of the field there's a lot of
things well in the red zone I really
like see Higgins I really really do and
if he runs a lot faster than we
projected maybe he just needs training
in the 40-yard dash because there are
times on the field where he does win
deep then that would be a huge stock
booster for him in a deep wide receiver
class it absolutely would and you know
with all these guys it's like it is too
early to say like one game matters but I
think one
this game really does matter forty
Higgins his ability to separate over the
top is big now running back Travis etn
it's funny because on this show I think
we've been really hot him for two years
but there's this narrative out there
that I don't like Travis etn I do it's
just a very good running back class and
I have a couple guys slotted ahead of
him what I love about Etienne though if
he goes to the right team and I'm
talking like a good outside zone team
he's going to be fantastic he has what I
think is the best speed of any running
back in this draft class however one
thing I was here Monday morning he might
go back to school now you're gonna hear
the argument of why tete you know what
like we so Nagi early in the show why
take more hits for free with Clemson
they believe they can do something truly
special with Trevor Lawrence coming back
next year Justin Ross is coming back a
lot of the offensive line will be back
so I do know that there's some thinking
out there that the Travis etn might
return to school against LSU they are so
much speed at linebacker and we talked
so much about their safeties that is one
thing I want to see how much is ETA news
tonight out of the backfield there's a
receiver
what is he able to do does he show some
power to his game because that is the
knock you have a guy who's 510 200
pounds can he show some power to match
up with that speed I have him right now
44 overall and compared to Chris Johnson
so really like Travis he was gonna say
no where the see j2k you write him a lot
I mean he would be right now the number
three back and forth he's the number
four back excuse me I have a Dobbins
Swift Johnson Taylor and Travis etn so
pretty good company
it's just it's a good running back class
yeah I have them 28th overall but fourth
running back for me too I mean I have it
Swift JT and Dobbins and they're all
very close to each other and then etn I
think the most important thing Matt is
that we've seen in games now like the
Ohio State game when he's taken out as a
runner he's becoming effective as a pass
catcher that's the most important growth
step for ETN and if he continues to do
that especially it's not against a good
LSU defense that's gonna make a really
big difference in his stock now if I was
him I you know I can't speak to what a
guy wants to do and etn is a really
interesting story that Adam creamer row
he was a late bloomer
he went to one of those camps ran a
blazing 40 and all sudden he's d1 offers
came in when there was none on the table
and that's open the door for his younger
brother to get looks now so he's kind of
a small-town vibe kind of guy he's not
this big flashy kind of guy maybe he
likes playing college football he likes
playing with Trevor Lawrence and maybe
he wants a chance for a potential second
or third national title next year so I
understand all of those things but when
you talk about running back mileage
which you did about nagi harrison
segment one that would be the most
important factor for me and as a running
back and a top 50 pick
I think etn should go to the NFL yeah
it's tough if you're running back and
you're gonna be a top hundred pick you
almost have to go now a player that I
actually thought was a redshirt
sophomore
I did not realize because you know we
just don't dig in on these guys until
it's time for them to declare I'm white
Rogers is a junior not a redshirt
sophomore that might seem like a weird
distinction to make but junior instead
of redshirt sophomore a lot of times
guys that's three years of tape you're
probably gonna be ready to jump faster
Amari Rodgers is interesting towards ACL
in the spring has not had a great year
statistically I wanted to throw him in
here because he is draft eligible we
have seen surprises I've not heard
anything about him coming out but he
would add an interesting layer to this
wide receiver class five foot ten really
really good speed when you watched the
Clemson offense it's so much about
Justin Ross and T Higgins Amari Rodgers
might be the guy tonight against LSU
where that third corner for LSU is gonna
have their work cut out for them when he
gets out there in the slot yeah and I
think him going back to school you know
does make some sense you have to wonder
you know six months of a torn ACL and
I'm not a doctor or son of the medical
report if it was a different tear
partially torn all I get to see is on
the on the internet is that it's a torn
ACL six months is fast Matt so one thing
I don't like to do ever and I know
you're the same way you never judge a
guy the first couple months back from
serious injury you know especially from
and we've seen it with a lot of talented
players so you know he's somebody that
can do a lot of different things on the
field and he's you know let's be real
he's been banged up quite a bit now in
college but he's a good player he's a
really really good play
and if he did surprisingly change his
mind and decide to declare for the
straps a is a phenomenal national title
you've seen this happen before
today's a fantastic game tonight and he
says you know I'm hot right now
I'm gonna leave then it adds a very
interesting wrinkle to a very deep wide
receiver class already but I Rodgers has
had flashes where you go damn who the
hell is that guy cuz I've seen T Hagen's
I've seen Justin Ross and he's somebody
that you know the opportunity tonight is
as big as anyone elses really is the the
stage is enormous on defense
my favorite player not name I say his
image for Clemson his corner AJ Terrell
he's also a junior I would expect him to
test the waters probably gonna come out
because it is a good corner class but I
think he slots into it pretty well I
actually have him graded number fourteen
seven overall right now 6 1 190 and we
haven't seen him against a lot of great
talent tonight could be a difference
maker if he can shut down Justin
Jefferson or Jamar chase whoever he's on
I think that's gonna change the
conversation because he could go ahead
of guys like Trayvon Diggs he could go
ahead of Jeff Gladney and so he puts
himself a more the conversation now if
he gets maust by Jamar chase all night
Brian not talking about him as a draft
prospect for 2020 and it's much too
passive doing one really is yeah I mean
I like him as well as a day to corner
right now I think he's got good length I
think we've seen him be one of those
guys that lived up to the hype a
five-star recruit eventually transforms
himself into an early starter and then a
first-team all-acc kind of player with
good ball production for a cornerback
that really shouldn't be tested too
often in that conference so once again
we talked about it with the Mauri
Rodgers the same can be said for AJ
Terrell because these LSU wide receivers
Matt are first-round guys and that's not
easy to do at wide receiver and we know
that what the Alabama guys I think
preseason we talked about it with the
Michigan guys but we were a little bit
disappointed mostly in the quarterback
yeah and I think we do it with the
Clemson guys a lot but LSU you know with
chase and Jefferson this is a phenomenal
group and once again this is that chance
for Terrell you look at how the knock on
Clemson all year or Clemson prospects is
well who are they doing it against well
now you get to do it against the best
yeah exactly and we always talk about
that you want these games for scouting
on the offensive line Clemson has two
guys John Simpson is a senior he is
slated to be at the Senior Bowl a power
player six foot forward 330 pounds then
he should go he should he really should
and he's an ass kicker I've really
enjoyed watching him play right tackle
Tremayne and Crum is a eligible junior I
don't think we'll see him leave it would
be a no I'm sorry he is a senior he is a
player that I am not that high on
looking at my rankings right now another
guy who is a senior ball player he is
incredibly small six foot to 290 so we
might see him get kicked inside to play
some guard I wouldn't even be surprised
he play some center at that size so
obviously you know the first note for me
and his strengths is the mobility is
unreal for him but he's playing a
position where we don't see a lot of 6-2
to 90 guys playing offensive tackle not
even Isaiah win and I think when you
look at players like that you know what
teams will dig into cuz Center it's a
tough position to move to you know and
you look at the IQ of the player hey can
they take on that transition and if
agram shows that like you said Matt he
has the mobility to make a really nice
adjustment to Center especially a team
that wants to run an outside zone kind
of scheme you look at what Kyle Shanahan
likes to do this sounds like his kind of
project and I always say that all the
time but I'm a little more excited just
to see him is Simpson because like you
said that that 330 pounds thick-billed
which he looks even bigger than that
sometimes when he gets his hands on you
it's over so Clemson it's hard because
and I'm guilty of this we get infatuated
with the skill talent they have eats
again all the wide receivers you know
the best quarterback we've seen in so
long for a young guy and Trevor Lawrence
but watch the offensive line sometimes
because there's a reason this offense
goes and those those guys in the
trenches you know they've been there for
a while being senior players they don't
get the credit they deserve all the time
and sure they're gonna have a tough task
against the speed and power of LSU
but if Clemson either makes this a game
or wins this game I think you have to
give some of those guys some big-time
credit that they don't always get yes
sir last Clemson player we're gonna
highlight his safety Kevon Wallace
another senior bowl guys
see a lot of tigers in two weeks and one
week excuse me at the 2020 race the
Senior Bowl come on Wallace has his work
cut out for him tonight because LSU's
nervous of all better than anyone in the
country whether it's you know that Moss
Terrence Marshall a guy who's been
dominant over the middle just in
Jefferson Jamar chase tracking Clyde
Clyde Edwards a lair who's so great out
of the backfield
Kevon Wallace is he's gonna get his
steps in tonight for sure because
they're gonna ask him to show off his
range and the safety position so as much
as Isaiah Simmons is a huge part of what
clemson does defensively I think come on
Wallace is a huge huge asset as well
because he has range over the top of
that defense and I think that's the most
important thing for him because he's one
of these smaller safeties Matt where you
need his coverage ability to shine Brian
I mean I know he's listed at 511 he's
probably more towards 510 maybe even
five nine and three-quarters kind of
player but when you can cover like that
that's gonna be needed so much I'm
curious to see what kind of pressure
clemson cooks up tonight because last
year we knew what we were getting when
those three guys that that went in the
first round right you know we knew what
we were getting with those Cleveland
Ferrell you pin your ears back and you
go you know what the X or Lawrence can
do in the middle Christian Wilkins I'm
curious to see how they use Simmons in
that role tonight and how much pressure
is put on these guys like Terrell and
Wallace to cover some of the best skill
talent in the entire country and chase
obviously maybe the best wide receiver
in all of college football yeah
letting a cuff winner big deal let's
take a break we come back whoo take a
breath because LSU has 16 players to
talk about they are loaded for the NFL
we've seen some amazing teams over the
years Alabama
Ohio State with a ton of draft prospects
Connor LSU's 15 players sorry I misspoke
15 players I'm evaluating tonight
not all of them maybe come out but I
know talking to people at LSU over the
last week they're worried then all these
underclassmen might follow Joe burrow
into the NFL they might see hey we got
to start over the quarterback next year
nah we'll just go with JB to the NFL and
that's where this conversation starts
Joe burrow is having a historic season
Melo said it to me the other day is the
best season season he's ever seen from a
college quarterback and he threw Vince
young into that list as well which I
thought was
a little crazy but then you look into it
77 percent of his passes 55 touchdowns
he's getting it done as a runner as well
hey Joe borough I think we've talked so
much about him as a college football
player this year that maybe we're inside
the bubble and not outside it maybe
we're too close to the situation but I
think he's not getting the credit he
deserves as a draft prospect because
where he was at week one a lot of people
like oh yeah Joe could have a good year
now where we are and like Jim nag he
said on the Friday show no one saw this
coming and so it almost feels like it's
time to catch up with how you know all
of us have Joe borough ranked highly but
he's it's not that he's just the default
guy because twoa got hurt he's a really
really good quarterback prospect in his
own right where that is at and I think
the jumps he made this year in this LSU
offense you know working under Brady
I've been phenomenal it's given him a
chance to shine but we've seen him take
steps I mean his feel in the pocket his
accuracy in the short and intermediate
areas of the field he's done so many
things well he's obviously a phenomenal
leader and I think it's you know how
long do we even have to talk about
jobber oh he's penciled in as the number
one pick for the Cincinnati Bengals you
heard Jim naggy say it right Zach Taylor
has called his family and said hey get
Joe down to mobile because we want to
start working with this guy we want to
get to know this guy and we want to be
around him and start their relationship
earlier and when you look at how much
the new NFL you know the CBA I shouldn't
call it new because it's gonna expire
soon but when you look at how much it
limits time coaches get not with just
with players but with their quarterbacks
I think that alone tells you how
Cincinnati feels about Joe borough and
it's it's all but a foregone conclusion
that this guy is gonna be the number one
pick and the NFL Draft and I think my
thing is that he deserves to be the year
that he's the player and person that he
is he deserves to be the number one pick
it's not like a consolation prize like
ah man if two had been healthy
I had borough over to it before he got
hurt that the hip injury at least I just
want to point that out I think Joe
baronies a little bit more loved than
he's had as a draft prospect now after
Boro LSU is incredibly deep and it's
mostly underclassmen safety grant Delpit
one of those guys we've talked about
Delpit this year where yeah he took a
little bit of a step back in history
your season but athleticism like this
leadership and character like this
doesn't come along very often it's not
that easy to find
I still have grant dumping as a top 15
player and no he's not the best tackler
in the world but I also think he held
back a little at times this year I
remember sitting in the stands watching
them play Georgia and was like oh
there's grant Delpit that's the guy
we've been waiting for and you watched
him again I saw Oklahoma oh there's the
dude so I want to see tonight what great
Delpit do we get this is most likely his
last college football game I want to see
him if we if he balls out I remember
having this conversation about Darwin
James with a lot of people like man he
does look the same this last year and
then he turned it on when it mattered I
want to see if Grant Delpit turns it on
tonight as well yeah so do I because
when you look at help it I thought what
made him so special as a freshman and
sophomore player was how much he's shown
in the spotlight and you said man I wish
I was evaluating that guy in this year's
draft back-to-back years then the year
comes where it's time to do that and the
film was not as good so this is a make
good chance for grant help it I think
you and I specifically Matt have stuck
by grants outfit more than anyone right
now I think is he a top 5 top 10 player
anymore no but we've said very firmly
he's a first round player that if he
goes 20 to 25 you might be looking back
and go man
maybe we over thought that one too much
because this guy's turned it on at the
next level in the NFL but I think Delpit
really needs a big game tonight to show
that listen when that when it matters
most I'm gonna throw my body around the
tackling isn't an issue and that I can
make plays both close to the line of
scrimmage and away from it exactly I
want to see him play more of that not
like reckless football but I want to see
him play with his hair on fire a little
bit the top senior for LSU is cornerback
christian fulton he's committed to the
senior bowl
i will do whatever it takes to make sure
this man gets to Mobile Alabama because
his physicality how sticky he is in
coverage is incredibly special and he's
battled an injury this year fulton they
like jeff vicunas my guy fulton is my
number 2 corner in this class he's one
of my favorite players too
I don't have a comp on him yet because I
thought I had one and then it scared me
and I backed off a little bit but I
really like Fulton he's ranked 18 on my
board and is a guy who and God slapped
me for saying this is a guy
Fulton early in his career had a drug
test fail you know he got himself right
everyone he talked to it LSU
just speaks to the turnaround that he
has made and I think teams are gonna buy
into that Christian Fulton is a new guy
that he's a better person and player
than he was early in his career and that
you're getting a truly special corner if
you draft him but you've fallen for me I
mean 15th overall my board I love what
he does in coverage I think in man
coverage this can be a top-flight corner
at the next level and he has the length
you know he's sticky in coverage I think
he can play the ball really well I think
you go back to the game against Alabama
where you saw him against the best of
the best
sure there were time where Henry rug's
got the best of him I think that's gonna
happen
they asked Fulton to line up one-on-one
against those Alabama wide receivers and
when you take the size as a whole uh you
know of measuring that performance snap
after snap he did a really really good
job and I think that's been the sum of
him
pretty much throughout his entire career
when he's been on the field he's done
such a good job all the time and I think
he's a better prospect ingredie williams
may be significantly a better prospect
ingredie williams right now I just think
fulton is a really really good player
that does all the things you ask of
corners at the next level so you know
underrated ly one of the most important
players to watch in this game but if you
don't hear his name called it's because
he's doing a really good job against
write a super tough task again he had it
against Alabama and now he gets it again
in Clemson you don't need to search for
film for Christian Fulton in this class
you're gonna get to know he's got it or
he doesn't and all the film I've watched
shows that he does yeah there's he'd be
a huge one for him tonight and Derrick
Stingley jr. on the other side of the
field a true freshman so we won't even
talk about him next year two years to
wait for that guy wide receiver for LSU
they're loaded but Jamar chased and
Terrence Marshall not draft eligible so
you turned to Justin Jefferson who was
huge against Oklahoma unstoppable I've
heard LSU coaches talk about the fact
that they watch the oh you film they're
like oh we're picking on that guy and
they knew Justin Jefferson was gonna
have a monster game and he did Justin is
such a smoother outrunner he is not the
biggest strongest guy but he is
incredibly smooth very productive he
seeks to about 190 my cop for him was
Davante Adams he is ranked right now
Connor at 33 overall on my big board in
a normal wide receiver class I bet he's
in the top 25 I mean he said the biggest
rise for me out of everyone I had to
scroll up to find him I've met 17 now
you see he's such a good route runner
he's a great player I think I love this
wide receiver class I didn't expect him
to jump over players like T Higgins and
ylvis' kishan all but he has he's a
really really good player I think you
know he might want to fill out a little
bit more and I think he will but he's
got good height good catch radius and
like you said he's a good route runner
where people are gonna watch this
offense and look how did the production
come out is it Joe Brady is it Joe
burrow is it the opposite is this Jamar
chase and and Jefferson and collided
it's everything in one this is a great
offense where a lot of top-flight NFL
talent is gonna come out of it and
Jefferson who's the second best wide
receiver on his team should be a
first-round pick in this year's draft
really should be and I think like to
your point you know I have KJ handler
above him and I believe s cachet and all
they're very different guys and so for
some teams you know they're gonna want
that you know speedy playmaker you know
twitchy guy after the catch others are
gonna want the route running with Justin
Jefferson he's a really good player
now the offensive line for LSU I'm gonna
group some of these dudes in together
excuse me
let's start with the edge Caleb and
chase on who is all about treats if you
want to see a player get drafted on
traits it's gonna be Kayla Vaughn chase
on there has been some Willie come out I
think he does
you don't Rock number 18 at LSU for two
seasons very often because that number
is a huge deal you've heard us talk to
Jacob Hester and Foster Murrow about it
so I think caleb on chase on comes out
you're not gonna pull his stats out me
like that's a hell of a football player
but watch him play especially when LSU
teams that throw the ball a lot you see
the speed he can dip his shoulder he can
bend he's got to get stronger that's a
huge part of this but I have Kaleb on
Chaisson I still have him in the first
round because I believe in his trait so
much so I have him at 23 overall and he
would be the the second or third edge in
this class I haven't tied with Tyrell
Lewis at Alabama but what he can do as a
dip and Bend guy his first step
quickness it's pretty pretty special
he's just incredibly raw right now and
one of the more interesting players in
this class I've met 30 overall and I can
see that a significant jump into the top
15 I think he'll test well I think once
again it feels like one of those edge
pass rushers that you're gonna look back
and see you know where is the production
now he turned it on at the end of the
year and that spin move is devastating
and people that don't like smaller pass
rushers on the edge the busts rate can
definitely be high at times are gonna
have fears of chase on now we talk about
gross Matos and and Brian burns
I think chase on actually might be even
closer to Brian burns some of the things
he does and the way he wins now is he
gonna get bullied at times of course he
is because he's a lighter player but I
think he'll work to put on weight
and I think he does he wins in a lot of
different ways a lot of that being the
speed the spin move I think what he did
again he basically made Alex Leatherwood
go back to school exactly very clear so
if you need any examples against good
players you know have to look much
further than that
yeah an LSU Georgia game what's another
one where it's like oh this guy is for
real now I do want to group the
offensive line together because they're
juniors left tackle Sadiq Charles and
senator Lloyd cushion Barry they could
both come out and I think they would
both be top 70 players if they come out
and that's that's just based on like I
watched them when you're watching
everyone else but offensive guard Damian
Lewis someone have really like watch a
play and then on the other side you have
Adrian Magee who's not getting as much
love but LSU could have four offensive
linemen drafted this year with Damian
Lewis I do have a late day two early day
three great on him he is mean playing
that right guard spot he is a power guy
if you look at this run game
they're very right-handed running the
football Damian Lewis is a huge part of
that he is a bit of a road grader
we have not seen him you know committed
to any all-star games
everyone else at LSU it seems like just
waiting for him to to make a decision
after tonight's game but I like Damien
Louis a lot if he gets you in a phone
booth you're done I mean holy [ __ ] I
think it was against Arkansas I
literally saw him pick someone up and
just throw them to the side on the
ground and just lead for a huge run I'm
curious to see what Charles and cushion
berry do there I can see them following
kind of what the Ohio State guys did and
going back to school but you also have
to wonder what offensive lineman do they
like to travel with their quarterback I
think that's what's interesting to me
like you said Matt some guys are gonna
follow Joe burrow to the NFL and it's no
slide on whoever plays quarterback for
LSU next year it just happens sometimes
with offensive lineman they could see
you know you know maybe a decline coming
and even if there isn't a decline for
LSU next year they just they feel
they've done enough but with Luis he's
the guy that he's going no matter what
and he's a power player he'll be very
scheme specific but there are a lot of
flashes on film where I go why isn't
this guy getting enough love right now
because he is really punishing people
out there he absolutely is and I think
with cushion berry
a sinner and Charles at left tackle
they're interesting players and this
offensive tackle class has incredible
depth so I could see Charles saying you
know next year like I'll come back and
Sewell is gonna be the first tackle
drafted but I might have a second you
know I mean you got Walker a little
coming back there's some good tackles
coming back next year but but you might
be a top 10 or 15 pick with another good
year so a tough decision for these guys
but they have talent on the offensive
line at LSU now running back Clyde
Edwards Allaire talking to Scouts last
week I was getting sneaky top 50 grades
on him which shocked me
because you don't look you look at his
body he's like he's 5-8 210 pounds like
how is this guy at top 50 player but he
catches the ball really really well out
of the backfield maybe the best receiver
out of the backfield in this entire
class and there's some guys who could
catch he has had monster games where
he's taken over this offense in games
where he's carried the offense a little
bit so we just talked about the
offensive line and how good they are so
you know my question it's gonna be it's
a one-year wonder how good would he be
without Joe Barrow opening up offenses
defenses and how good we be without this
d-line but I'll tell you there's a lot
of like 4c eh in the NFL I'm not
surprised because number one he profiles
identically to Mark Ingram so if you
liked Mark Ingram you're gonna like like
Clyde Edwards Hilaire and I don't really
believe in taking a guy like that round
one but I could easily see him deserving
to go in round two and once again if nah
she goes back to school if the etn goes
back to school that's where you know
Clyde Clyde the glide bumps up easily he
projects Murray right up in there great
balance great contact balance I think he
runs low to the ground which is you've
seen him use his power and take
advantage of that running style and like
you said Maddie catches the ball so well
so Clyde Edwards Hilaire I know he's
been banged up this year at times which
cooled him off a little bit but there
was a time where he was skyrocketing up
and I would not be shocked at all to
hear his name called in round 2 I
actually think that's exactly where
he'll go but top 50 that's juicy for him
that's juicy for any running back yeah I
mean like you wouldn't think about round
2 it's like this travis ET n slip and
they're just cam akers we're waiting to
hear what naxi harris does I was running
back class could get really really good
really really famous way better than
Akers I think so yeah Akers is tough
because not to get off on another team
Akers is tough because he had nothing
around him at all so they're almost
polar opposites in that way now we could
look at the linebackers and the safeties
not named grant Delpit because LSU is
stocked there as well
Patrick Queen Jacob Phillips Patrick
Queen
he's like Kenneth Murray that no one
talks about his range his speed sideline
to sideline
I have not graded him because the
expectation was that he would go back to
school if he comes out the things I've
seen man I think I would probably put
him inside the top 40 I really really
like his game he's six one like 235 him
he's Pro built and he has been all over
the field now Jacob Phillips someone I
gave around three grade two when I was
asked by Scouts and agents where I liked
him I put a day three on him his
instincts just aren't there yet but he's
body beautiful six for 230 he can run
like the wind his instincts just aren't
quite developed enough yet and then you
have the safeties not just grant Delpit
but you have jacory Jacoby Stephen
Kerry Vincent jr. they both play really
well near the line of scrimmage
especially Kerry Vincent jr. we've seen
some hits from him this year that are
really really nice but again both guys
are juniors they might want their chance
to go back to LSU and be grand Delpit
next year and be Christian Fulton next
year so I think with those two and with
the two linebackers there's been some
rumblings there there at least testing
the waters but I hope we see those four
guys go back to school I'm not too
surprised there I think when you look at
Phillips just the way his high profile
is a six for 230 and like you said Matt
how good he runs there was a lot of
production from both of these
linebackers during the 2018 season where
we had a good feel for them coming into
this year where I think we both said on
the previous show they're gonna be fine
you lose Devon white yeah that sucks but
they had two guys ready to come in ready
to flourish right away so for the
Alabama for the LSU front seven if
you're gonna trust anyone developing
some front seven players I think they're
good there and I'm not surprised I think
they could both benefit going back to
school because I think the hype would
increase for them you would go in
knowing that hey these are to its
potential top linebackers in the country
I still think this defense will be very
very good obviously having a premier
player on the outside and Stingley is
very important they recruit very well
all over the defense every year even
when LSU was not this top-five program
they've always recruited very well in
the defensive side of the ball so I
could see both sides to it I could see
both players easily being de 2 picks if
you know obviously they show out at the
combine they run pretty well they test
pretty well but I think if they go back
to school they start to play themselves
maybe more into that top 40 top 50 range
instead yeah and I last guy I want to
talk about is Rashard Lawrence who every
time you watch LSU play this dude makes
big place but he's just not getting a
ton of draft buzz which surprises me a
little bit he's a senior I really like
him and I have him graded as maybe
around 3 guy I mean he's 6 3 3 17 but he
penetrates he sees the run he's just
incredibly smart and for some reason
he's not getting a love which actually
sounds like I probably need to move him
higher because I really like this player
the more I talk about him
but you don't you don't get the you
talked to Scouts about D lineman or even
LSU no one talks about Rashard Lawrence
but I'll bet you $5.00 the student makes
place tonight every time you watch LSU
play he's getting things done from the
interior D line position well I thought
he was gonna declare last year I do you
remember how much he's dominated in the
Fiesta Bowl he had a phenomenal game
against UCF and I remember watching him
all year because we got to see LSU on
the first tailgate tour against Georgia
so we knew a lot about that football
team and I'm like oh Laurence is junior
defensive lineman's really good player
holds it Clair watched a ton of him he
goes back to school and you almost
forget about him because they have so
many good players in this phenomenal
season so I'm with you all the way there
is he one of those you know not the
biggest guy all the time especially hi
he's more compact player yes but we've
seen so many of those guys excel
recently and Lawrence has years of
production right now where I really like
him I mean this is the last three years
he's played very very well and I'm
excited to see his send-off in college
football one of the more
underappreciated players not just for
LSU but on defense in college football
the last two seasons yeah he is a lot of
fun to watch tonight it's going to be
amazing and I'm gonna put you on the
spot this wasn't in the rundown but we
have a serious game I'm taking LSU
because I picked against them once
earlier this year and I may never do it
again I'm taking LSU in this one I do
think it will be a close game because of
how good this Clemson offense is I just
don't know if Clemson has the defense to
stop Joe burrow so I'm doing my same
championship rant from last year I'm
taking Clemson's points and I think LSU
wins last year I said I took Clemson's
points but I thought Alabama wins I won
the bet but Clemson steamrolled Alabama
I don't think that'll be the case I do
think LSU caps off a brilliant year but
man I got Clemson at plus five and a
half so I know LSU has been brilliant I
know they're great
I think Clemson is great as well and I
could see this being a three point game
that comes down to the wire and guess
what the Tigers are gonna win anyway
yeah right there you go the Tigers are
winning that's right
for tonight you should be a great game
tweet at us when you hear this let us
know who you're picking or who you're
excited to watch it's at stick to
football
it is draft on draft time we got five
awesome questions for you guys and I
apologize if you're watching on YouTube
you noticed I've been looking at typing
a lot today what you're trying to get
things ready for the Senior Bowl and
apparently every agent in the world
today wants to know where their guys are
graded so I apologize if you've seen me
being mr. typey fingers today but Connor
first question my guy Todd rice
are there any positions other than
quarterback we're being a one-year
starter can hurt a player stock are
there certain positions where it does
matter in certain ones where it doesn't
I I always feel like with a one-year
wonder guy and one thing I try to
explain is that was scouting we're
always learning
hopefully we're always getting better
and I've been burned on someone your
wonder guys where it's like Mitchell
true Biscay is the obvious one where I
say oh he was so good for one year he'll
just keep getting better and he hasn't
so I think you have to be aware of it if
you're one you're wondering back it's
probably not gonna hurt you as much
because we've seen it before where as
long as you are athletic you're when
you're wandering running back to me that
just means you have been hit a lot think
about Josh Jacobs last year played for
three years to Alabama what was really a
one-year wonder some when it came time
to evaluate him it's like oh he hasn't
had the wear and tear of a normal
Alabama running back this is amazing and
it didn't hurt him that because he was
such a good athlete with power with
speed with burst division that you knew
it would translate so I think with
everything you got to put the player in
the bubble which is something I try to
work to be a lot better at and you have
to erase your confirmation bias you know
and I think that's where a lot of us get
burned with players is you feel like you
watch two three games you know the
player and then you look for everything
to point back to them being that guy
instead of keeping an open mind about it
I also think the one-year wonder label
needs context like you can be a one-year
wonder in the ACC and your team didn't
make the playoff and you're sitting
there and you're going well let me find
the toughest game he played against the
toughest competition and then you're
sitting there and you go maybe I do have
some reservations and then you could
also have a one-year wonder like let's
be real Joe borough as a superstar
quarterback is a one-year wonder Joe
burrow has also lit up
phenomenal college football teams week
after week after week and he's done it
at the highest level non-stop so there's
a different one-year wonder as in mr.
Biscay verse jobber oh now I know Joe
Burrell was more than a 1 year starter I
get that but in terms I mean Matt we had
Joe Burrell projected round like three
to five before the season yeah that's a
quarterback prospect now he's the number
one overall pick in ink so it's it's
different
I think context is important and I think
there are a lot of different one-year
wander players like who is the safety
Holloman Girard Holloman LSU yeah that
was that was so interesting one here
like 14 interceptions he had all the
interceptions yeah so you go back and
you watch those interceptions and you go
you know how is he getting these and and
why is this one year phenomenal wonder
of projection
I think Brendan Whedon's another
interesting guy because he was an older
quarterback that had this one brilliant
year so it's it it is to answer the
question about players that can hurt
their stock I don't think it's
positional based I think a lot of it is
just context of how they got that one
year whether it was really good or
really bad and what factors caused that
Jack Pollard a question that is so close
to the hearts of the stick to football
host that's a good one should Joe
Montana do the coin toss if the Super
Bowl is Kansas City verse San Francisco
here's the thing I don't I put this
question in here I don't know if a lot
of people know this we had Joe Montana
on the show we were really fortunate to
get that interview one of the my career
highlights Joe Montana does not like to
do stuff like this like you would
they'll do things in San Francisco like
oh come meet the great Niners of all
time Joe Montana will not be there he
does not have a lot to do with that
organization like my man is trying to
sell Skechers that is all he cares about
but that pays the bills right so I don't
know if he would show up you know I
really don't so I think it's interesting
to see like even when they did the MVP
thing I was at that Super Bowl was in
San Francisco they walked out like all
50 MVPs or whatever and it was like a
weird response to Joe Montana so I I
just man it he's an interesting dude
well the greatest quarterbacks of all
time
I love Joe Montana but
III do think that gosh there are I don't
know if they could talk him into it like
I think yesterday Dell would have to
personally big yeah but if you do that
what's the fun and like if he doesn't
want to be there don't do it right so a
but I'm it's a great idea
you have Steve Bono do it like come on
it's a great idea that it it just might
not pan out
Patrick Howie with our next question
here with Swift Taylor Dobbins and Eaton
getting the majority of the running back
love are there any other running backs
with later round value that you like
what we did a big one today and Clyde
Edwards Hilaire yeah you know we talked
about cam akers a little bit i like cam
akers I think with him is you you gotta
get him out of that scheme almost and
try to evaluate him that way you know we
talked to Ino Benjamin a couple weeks
ago I liked him a lot as a third down
receiving back Joe Michael hasty a
Baylor tone of speed I liked him a lot
my favorite all-around running back
that's not you know top 75 guy is
Keyshawn Vaughn from Vanderbilt meets me
we talked so much about him top senior
running back headed into the year and
then Vandy just didn't play well you
know we didn't see the production from
him or Kalasha Lipscomb or Jerry Pinkney
that we expected so I really like Keisha
of on I think in a week people will be
talking in two weeks
people be talking about him a lot more
than they all right now because I think
he'll be the best back at the Senior
Bowl I don't even think it's close to be
honest with you when you look at that
running back group I'm another one that
people are really high on that we're
curious to keep an eye on but I know in
general people really like Zach Moss
that's gonna be an interesting one to
follow I want to see how he runs
interviews a lot of different things
there see him at the Senior Bowl and we
will not see him at the Senior Bowl so
that's a little disappointing um yeah
it's a deep running back class I mean we
were saying earlier in the show naxi
Harris could go back to school that
takes a big one off the board because I
think he could be in that group of four
that you named earlier yeah there's a
lot of talented players there really are
and if you can find starters on day two
you really can you might even find some
starters on day three that we've seen
before the next one from Carson Fritchie
matt has been harassed to say the least
by people on Twitter
over a certain prospect that shall not
be named have any of you ever had a take
on a prospect that gets people this
worked up every year every year and so I
love this question for a lot of reasons
I am currently dealing with people
bringing up like a November take on
Derek Henry from his senior season and I
was wrong and I think like that's the
thing that makes me different makes us
different is that I'll tell you I was
wrong and then I'll tell you why I was
wrong with Derek Henry dude had more
carries in high school football than
anyone in history and then Nick Saban
ran him into the ground that last year
so I really thought man here's this 6-3
250-pound guy with this many carries
I've never seen a prospect like Derek
Henry hit and you can look at the NFL
there's no one else like him right now
and so you get into like I said earlier
a little bit of a confirmation bias of
all those carries all those hits I've
never seen someone at 6-3 250 have
success in the modern NFL where at the
time everyone was getting smaller not
bigger so and I I'm not trying to say I
was right in any way but Derek Henry's
first two years he wasn't good he event
he got in the right system we talked
about this all the time he got in the
right situation he talked to Eddie
George made some changes about his game
about his workouts and now he is the
best running back in the NFL for the
2019 season he's having a historic run
through the playoffs so yeah I mean
people will get on you pre draft and
post draft about a player it's just the
nature of the business and I think
because we a bleacher report are more
interactive than the other networks
you're going to get more of that you
invite it more by being interactive it's
just it's part of the job that you have
to deal with but I think the key for me
I've been doing this I'm about to start
my 10th year doing this and you just
have to be like I was wrong it's gonna
happen again but here's what I tried to
learn from that with Derek Henry what
I've learned is there going to be
outliers some guys are just anomalies
and you know Russell Wilson's another
one you watch Russell Wilson playing
college here like that dudes a
first-round pick but at the time a 5-10
quarterback had not succeeded in the NFL
and so you you bet on that ninety-nine
point nine out of a hundred that don't
make it and every now and then there's
gonna be that guys it's that that point
one that hits I mean you're watching
over 400 players a year
you're gonna get some wrong it happens
now I think you make a great point Matt
that you uh you me and mellow and
bleacher report in general is much more
interactive than other media brands as
analysts now that is through a lot of
different channels I think you and I
notably on Twitter I think you know we
do dabble in Instagram especially lives
on Instagram and I also think now the
big one being the Bleacher Report app is
very interactive because a lot of our
clip outs from this show and
conversations from the show live in the
Bleacher Report app where it's going to
the fans of those teams and if they
don't agree with you you know you get a
nice sometimes I wake up to
notifications of people commenting like
like [ __ ] you this whatever right oh
yeah just like you know conversation so
I love being interactive and it's just
part of it and you're going to miss and
it happens I think my favorite example
is I had someone who followed me for a
long time on Twitter they blocked me on
Twitter because I liked that Oliver more
than Quinton Williams and they told me
that they go I don't understand how you
can like it Oliver more than Quinton
Williams and I'm blocking you and I was
like ok so just being honest and Oliver
was much better than Quinton Williams
this year now I hope Quinton Williams
turns it on and is phenomenal these next
couple years but there's just how some
people are really good at understanding
disagreements and some people including
yourself are really good at just owning
things owning misses because if you
can't own your misses and this is a
great example for the last question
we're gonna have here you won't last in
this business know you won't know you'll
flame out really quickly yeah last
question and this is when we get a lot
but it's always fun to answer and iTunes
or Apple podcast questions to send out
you can still comment there five star
review will probably get your question
answered ride from Chicago
how do you become a scout for an NFL
team what needs to be on your resume and
what are the first steps to getting
there you know a long time ago I tried
this route this was what I wanted to do
out of high school was to be an NFL
scout and you know life had different
plans for me so the one thing that I
learned 18 years ago was that you needed
to know someone it was who you know
because that's the first step now what I
tell I teach scouting classes over the
summer
and the money goes to my my charity that
I run and what I tell every guy who I
talked to over the summer is that if
you're in college walk right now to the
football operations building and say
what can I do I will in turn I'll do
laundry I'll paint the field what can I
do because the most NFL scouts these
days are coming from college where they
worked for the football team that is the
best way to get in if you're outside of
college you want to look for an
internship you can look on you know NFL
teams post jobs all the time you can
follow those teams on Twitter they'll
talk about their internships but that is
the best way is to try to get an
internship if you're in college or if
you're out of college to get an
internship with NFL team unfortunately
if you were 35 years old and working in
accounting right now it's probably not
gonna happen unless you know someone who
works for a team and they're willing to
give you an entry-level position that
you can afford to take because the money
will not be good to start with most
teams do a two-year scouting internship
and it is paid but it's gonna be like 25
or 30 thousand dollars a year and you're
probably a little with three other
people because NFL teams are in big
cities where it cost a lot to live so
it's I'm not trying to discourage anyone
there aren't a lot of jobs and like
Connor said to get those jobs so there's
32 teams let's say each team has ten
jobs it's 320 scouting jobs how many
people do you think want that job you
gotta be willing to out sacrifice and
outwork everyone else who wants that job
without it I mean there's so many
factors and do it I remember you know
there was a time and I believe you might
have even been with me when I could have
pushed should try to get an internship
as a scouting intern yeah II do remember
I was 24 25 years old and it already
would have been over a 50% pay cut
almost 65 percent and sometimes you get
into a situation in life where you can't
do that and I tell people this all the
time that wanna make it there are simple
things that you're gonna have to accept
a lot of basically all the time you're
gonna have to relocate number two you're
gonna have to figure it out financially
in ways that you would never ever expect
and if you're in the position to even
have to worry about those things you've
made it much further than just about
everyone
else most people don't even have the
opportunity so I think it's it's really
interesting path I think like you said
Matt it is about who you know because
you and I did not play football at a
high level where we sit there and go oh
you know now the path is I finished
playing college football now I'll go
back as a ga and just find my path right
there where there's no work though for
me yeah it's like how it works for a lot
of people right really a lot of the the
players number one they have the
interest but number two the guys that
the staff knew we're really intelligent
guys you get to be a ga you work in some
kind of form now if you like matt said
if you're just a student you can find
ways to help a lot of it is in
recruiting recruiting offices
you should learn skills that you would
never expect making graphics editing
video how to cut a video doing all those
things
these guys need people that can cut up
film these guys need people that can
make graphics for recruits or be there
to let them recruit into the facilities
to unlock the doors these are things
that you have to do or if you don't even
if you want to work on the strength
staff like you're gonna have to work
your way up as an intern fetching water
mopping the floors there's so many
different things in different ways to do
it if you want to and you believe you
could do it I truly am a believer that
anyone can make it happen but you don't
realize the amount of sacrifices that
you have to make and honestly I'll say
this now that I've been around it for a
very long time it is one of the most
erratic lifestyles I have ever witnessed
like I grew up in a house where you know
my parents went to work and then they
come home now a little more erratic than
most cuz my dad works 24 hour shifts as
a firefighter in the city but still
normal Scouts are gone sometimes for 30
days in a row yeah or you're fired and
you don't have a job and you don't you
might be out of the league and you need
to find a new career I think that's the
side of it that doesn't get talked about
enough that's not the glamorous side of
it right yeah I mean you think of it all
the teams that just got fired it's a lot
of scouting you know the Browns whole
scouting department could get fired
those guys got to go find jobs so it is
it's a huge part of it and I'll say a
lot of that same advice applies to media
if you want to if you want to my job one
of the
days you have to be willing to there are
even less of these jobs than there are
scouting jobs so the the pool gets even
smaller a lot of its who you know it's
not as much like oh where you went to
college but who you know who you can
network with and then getting in at the
ground floor I started here as an unpaid
writer who no one had ever heard of and
and now they will have to literally drag
me from the building to get me to ever
leave this place than that you know what
I'll say this this is something that
when people message me and they ask for
honest advice I often say listen if you
want to find your way in and you're
young you're going to college or you're
in the middle of college I would learn a
soak up as much stats data and
mathematics classes you can and invest
yourself in analytics because that's the
most jobs that are opening up in the NFL
right now every single team if they
don't have one they're making analytics
department that might have four five six
seven eight jobs schemes hire analytics
guys as freelancers I mean there's
people on Twitter that worked for NFL
teams that you wouldn't even know about
so I think if you truly want in you have
to do something different you can't
always just sit there and and I love
what we do we get to watch a million
players go through the tape but that's
not always the most direct way in now
anymore
yeah or get really really good at social
media because every team is hiring that
guy so there's a lot of ways in but none
of them are easy so that is our show
good luck tonight LSU and Clemson no
matter who wins it's gonna be a fun game
and we'll be back Wednesday morning
we'll see what happens it might be a
mock draft it might be looking back at
LSU Clemson might be looking forward to
the Senior Bowl there's a lot going on
right now but we can guarantee you a fun
show for Connors mat without Yale real
soon